[Music]
here we go again
hang on isn't this two weeks early well
yet it is and if you are watching the
latest state of play from playstation
you'll have seen this
hunters arena legends the next game we
will be receiving as ps plus subscribers
for the month of august 2021
between tuesday the 3rd of august and
the 6th of september
both ps4 and ps5 owners can download
this
free of charge here's what to expect
hunter's arena legend
is a battle royale those words will
either make you interested or make you
run and hide
hear me out though this is not a
standard br hunter's arena takes 30
players and asks them to make the living
snot out of each other
this battle royale is focused on melee
martial arts and swordplay
the call mode throws 30 hunters into a
world which also has ai characters
and grunts to fight so this is more of a
pvp ve
setup with many mmo and rpg elements too
in-game dungeons and unique demons can
be found to battle to garner improved
loot
ready for the next fight with a real
player the second mode at launch is
trios
a surprisingly tactical version where
you and two buddies team up together
each hunter is set up differently with
skill and ability adjustments
and there's even a kung fu panda like
the other battle royales there is a
boatload of customization to dip into
to get your historically accurate
kinochi right or otherwise dress up like
this you do you from the early access
version i played i can tell you that
timing has an importance here and
knowledge of the environment can be the
difference between death and victory
hunters arena legends releases on ps
plus on august 3rd
but the real question is will you try it
or is this another battle royale which
is going to struggle to find a player
base
i'll be sure to make another video as
soon as we know the other official games
coming in the august update i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time